The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So last
time, we started
looking at the system
of [? spins. ?] So there
was a field S of
x on the lattice.
And the energy cost was
proportional to differences
of space on two
neighboring sites,
which if we go to the continuum,
became something like gradient
of the vector S. You have to
integrate this, of course,
over all space.
We gave this a rate of K over 2.
There was some energy costs
[INAUDIBLE] of this [? form ?]
so that the particular
configuration
was weighted by this factor.
And to calculate the
partition function,
we had to integrate over
all configurations of this
over this field S.
And the constraint that we had
was that this was a unit vector
so that this was an n component
field whose magnitude was 1,
OK?
So this is what we
want to calculate.
Again, whenever we are writing
an expression such as this,
thinking that we started with
some average system [INAUDIBLE]
some kind of a coarse graining.
There is a short distance
[INAUDIBLE] [? replacing ?]
all of these tiers.
Now what we can do is
imagine that this vector
S in its ground
state, let's say,
is pointing in some particular
direction throughout the system
and that fluctuations
around this ground
state in the
transverse direction
are characterized by
some vector of pi that
is n minus 1 dimensional.
And so this partition function
can be written entirely
[? rather ?] than fluctuations
of the unit vector S in terms
of the fluctuations of these
transverse [? coordinates ?]
[INAUDIBLE] pi.
And we saw that the
appropriate weight
for this n minus 1
component vector of pi
has within it a factor of
something like square root of 1
minus pi squared.
There's an overall factor
of 2, but it doesn't matter.
And essentially, this says that
because you have a unit vector,
this pi cannot get too big.
You have to pay
[? a cost ?] here,
certainly not larger than 1.
And then the expression
for the energy costs
can be written in terms of
two parts [? where it ?]
is the gradient
of this vector pi.
But then there's
also the gradient
in the other direction
which has magnitude
square root of 1
minus pi squared.
So we have this
gradient squared.
And so basically,
these are two ways
of writing the same thing, OK?
So we looked at this
and we said that once
we include all of these
terms, what we have here is
a non-linear [? activity ?]
that includes,
for example, interactions
among the various modes.
And one particular
leading order term
is if we expand this square
root of 1 minus pi squared,
if it would be something
like pi square root of pi,
so a particular term in this
expansion as the from pi
[? grad ?] pi multiplied
with pi [? grad ?] pi.
[INAUDIBLE], OK?
So a particular way of dealing
these kinds of theories
is to regard all of these
things as interactions
and perturbations with respect
to a Gaussian weight which
we can compute easily.
And then you can either do that
perturbation straightforwardly
or from the beginning to a
perturbative [? origin, ?]
which is the route
that we chose.
And this amount to
changing the short distance
cut off that we
have here that is
a to be b times a and
averaging over all [? nodes ?]
within that distance short
wavelength between a and ba.
And once we do that, we
arrive at a new interaction.
So the first step is
to do a coarse graining
between the range a and ba.
But then steps two
and three amount
to a rescaling in position space
so that the cut-off comes back
to ba and the corresponding
thing in the spin space
so that we start with a
partition function that
describes unit vectors.
And after this
transformation, we
end up with a new
partition function
that also describes
unit vectors so
that after all of
these three procedures,
we hope that we are
back to exactly the form
that we had at the beginning
with the same cut-off,
with the same unit
vector constraint,
but potentially with a new
interaction parameter K
And calculating
what this new K is
after we've scaled by a factor
of b, the parts that correspond
to 2 and 3 are
immediately obvious.
Because whenever I see x, I
have to replace it wit bx prime.
And so from
integration, I then get
a factor of b to the d
from the two gradients,
I would get a factor of minus 2.
So the step that corresponds
to this is trivial.
The step that corresponds to
replacing S with zeta S prime
is also trivial.
And it will give
you zeta squared.
Or do I have yet to
tell you what is?
We'll do that shortly.
And finally, the first step,
which was the coarse graining,
we found that what it did
was that it replaced K
by a strongly-- sorry.
I didn't expect this.
All right-- the factor K, which
is larger by a certain amount.
And the mathematical
justification
that I gave for this is we
look at this expression,
and we see that in
this expression,
each one of these pi's
can be a long wavelength
fluctuation or a short
wavelength fluctuation.
Among the many possibilities
is when these 2 pi's
that are sitting
out front correspond
to the short wavelength
fluctuations.
These correspond to the long
wavelength fluctuations.
And you can see that
averaging over these two
will generate an
interaction that
looks like gradient
of pi lesser squared.
And that will change the
coefficient over here
by an amount that is clearly
proportional to the average
of pi greater squared.
And that we can see
in Fourier space
is simply 1 over
Kq squared over KK
squared for modes that
have wave number K.
So if I, rather than
write this in real space,
I write it in
Fourier space, this
is what I would get
for the average.
And in real space, I have
to integrate over this K
appropriately [INAUDIBLE] within
the wave numbers lambda over
[? real ?] [? light. ?] And this
is clearly something that is
inversely proportional to K. And
the result of this integration
of 1 over K squared-- we
simply gave a [? 9 ?],
which was i sub d of b.
Because it depends
on the dimension.
It depends on
[? et ?] [? cetera. ?]
AUDIENCE: Sir?
PROFESSOR: Yes?
AUDIENCE: Shouldn't
there be an exponential
inside the integral?
PROFESSOR: Why should
there be an exponential
inside the integral?
AUDIENCE: Oh, I thought we
were Fourier transforming.
PROFESSOR: OK, it is true,
when we Fourier transform
for each pi, we will have
a factor of e to the IK.
If we have 2 pi's, I will get
e to the IK e to the IK prime.
But the averaging
[INAUDIBLE] set
K and K prime can be
opposite each other.
So the exponentials disappear.
So always remember the
integral of any field squared
in real space is the same
thing as the integral
of that field squared
in Fourier space.
This is one of
the first theorems
of Fourier transformation.
OK, so this is a correction
that goes like [INAUDIBLE].
And last time, to give you a
kind of visual demonstration
of what this factor is, I
said that it is similar,
but by no means
identical to something
like this, which is that a mode
by itself has very low energy.
But because we have coupling
among different modes,
here for the Goldstone
modes of the surface,
but here for the Goldstone
modes of the spin,
the presence of a certain amount
of short range fluctuations
will stiffen the modes that you
have for longer wavelengths.
Now, I'm not saying that these
two problems are mathematically
identical.
All I'm showing you
is that the coupling
between the short and
long wavelength modes
can lead to a stiffening of
the modes over long distances
because they have to fight
off the [? rails ?] that
have been established by
shorter wavelength modes.
You have to try to undo them.
And that's an
additional cost, OK?
Now, that stiffening over here
is opposed by a factor of zeta
over here.
Essentially, we
said that we have
to ensure that what we
are seeing after the three
steps of RG is a
description of a [? TOD ?]
that has the same short distance
cut-off and the same length
so that the two partition
functions can map on
to each other.
And again, another
visual demonstration
is that you can decompose
the spin over here
to a superposition of short
and long wavelength modes.
And we are averaging over
these short wavelength modes.
And because of that, we will
see that the effective length
once that averaging has been
performed has been reduced.
It has been reduced because I
will write this as 1 minus pi
squared over 2 to
the lowest order.
And pi squared has n
minus 1 components.
So this is n minus 1 over 2.
And then I have
to integrate over
all of the modes pi
alpha of K in this range.
So I'm performing exactly
the same integral as above.
So the reduction is precisely
the same integral as above, OK?
So the three steps of RG
performed for this model
to lowest order
in this inverse K,
our [? temperature-like ?]
variable is given by this one
[INAUDIBLE] once I substitute
the value of zeta over there.
So you can see that
the answer K prime of b
is going to b to
the b minus 2 zeta
squared-- ah, that's right.
For zeta squared,
essentially the square
of that, 1 minus
n minus 1 over K,
the 2 disappears
once I squared it.
Id of b divided by K-- that
comes from zeta squared.
And from here I can get
the plus Id of be over K.
And the whole thing gets
multiplied by this K.
And there is still terms at
the order of temperature of 1
over K squared, OK?
And finally, we are going
to do the same choice
that we were doing for
our epsilon expansion.
That is, choose a
rescaling factor that
is just slightly larger than 1.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Sir, you're at n
minus 1 over K times Id over K.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I
gave this too much.
Thank you.
OK, thank You.
And we will write K prime at Kb
to be K plus delta l dK by dl.
And we note that for
calculating this Id of b, when
b goes to 1 plus delta
l, all I need to do
is to evaluate this integrand
essentially on the shell.
So what I will get is lambda
to the power of d minus 2.
The surface area of a unit
sphere divided by 2 pi
to the d, which is the
combination that we
have been calling K sub d, OK?
So once I do that, I will
get that the dK by dl, OK?
What do I get?
I will get a d minus
2 here times K.
And then I will get
these two factors.
There's n minus 1.
And then there's 1 here.
So that becomes n minus 2.
I have a Idb, which is Kd
lambda to the d minus 2.
And then the 1 over
K and K disappear.
And so that's the
expression that we have.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Sorry, is the Kd
[? some ?] angle factor again?
PROFESSOR: OK, so you have
to do this integration, which
is written as the surface
area inside an angle,
K to the d minus 1 dK
divided by 2 pi to the d.
This is the combination that
we have always called K sub d.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: OK?
Now, it actually
makes more sense
since we are making a
low temperature expansion
to define a T that is
simply 1 over K. Its
again, dimensionless.
And then clearly
dT by dl is going
to be minus K squared dK by
dl minus 1 over K squared.
Minus 1 over K squared becomes
minus T squared dK by dl.
So I just have to
multiply the expression
that I have up here
with minus T squared,
recognizing that TK is 1.
So I end up with the
[? recursion ?] convention
for T, which is
minus d minus 2T.
And then it becomes plus n minus
2 Kd lambda to the d minus 2 T
squared.
And presumably, there
are high order terms
that we have not
bothered to calculate.
So this is the
[INAUDIBLE] we focused on.
OK?
So let's see whether this
expression makes sense.
So if I'm looking at dimensions
that are less than 2,
then the linear term
in the expression
is positive, which means that if
I'm looking at the temperature
axis and this is 0, and
I start with a value that
is slightly positive,
because of this term,
it will be pushed larger
and larger values.
So you think that
you have a system
at very low temperatures.
You look at it at larger
and larger scales,
and you find that it
becomes effectively
something that has
higher temperature
and becomes more
and more disordered.
So basically, this is a
manifestation of something
that we had said before,
Mermin-Wagner theorem, which
is no [? long ?] range
order in d less than 2, OK?
Now, if I go to the other
limit, d greater than 2,
then something
interesting happens,
in that the linear
term is negative.
So if I start with a
sufficiently small temperature
or a large enough coupling,
it will get stronger
as we go towards
an ordered phase,
whereas the quadratic
term for n greater than 2
has the opposite sign--
this is n greater than 2--
and pushes me towards disorder,
which means that there should
be a fixed point that
separates the two behaviors.
Any temperature lower than this
will give me an ordered phase.
Any temperature higher
than this will give me
a disordered phase.
And suddenly, we see that
we have potentially a way
of figuring out what the phase
transition is because this T
star is a location that we
can perturbatively access.
Because we set this
to 0, and we find
that T star is
equal to d minus 2
divided by n minus 2 Kd
lambda to the d minus 2.
So now in order to have
a theory that makes sense
in the sense of the perturbation
that we have carried out,
we have to make sure
that this is small.
So we can do that by assuming
that this quantity d minus 2
is a small quantity in making
an expansion in d minus 2, OK?
So in particular,
T star itself we
expect to be related to
transition temperature, not
something that is universal.
But exponents are universal.
So what we do is we
look at d by dl of delta
T. Delta T is,
let's say, T minus T
star in one direction
or the other.
[INAUDIBLE]
And for that, what
I need to do it
to linearize this expression.
So I will get a minus
epsilon from her.
And from here, I will
get 2 n minus 2 Kd lambda
to the d minus 2 T
star times delta T.
I just took the derivative,
evaluated the T star.
And we can see that this
combination is precisely
the combination that I
have to solve for T star.
So this really becomes
another factor of epsilon.
I have minus epsilon
plus [? 2 ?] epsilon.
So this is epsilon delta
T. So that tells me
that my thermal
eigenvalue is epsilon,
a disorder clearly
independent of n.
Now, we've seen that in
order to fully characterize
the exponent, including things
like magnetization, et cetera,
it makes sense to also put
a magnetic field direction
and figure out how rapidly you
go along the magnetic field
direction.
So for that, one
way of doing this
is to go and add to this term,
which is h integral S of x.
And you can see very easily
that under these steps
of the transformation,
essentially the only thing that
happens is that I will
get h prime at scale
d is h from the integration.
I will get a factor
of b to the d.
From the replacement
of s with s prime,
I will get a factor of zeta.
So this combination
is simply my yh.
And just bringing a
little bit of manipulation
will tell you that yh
is d minus the part that
comes from zeta,
which is n minus 1
over 2 Id of b, which is
lambda to the d minus 2 Kd.
And then we have T star.
And again, you
substitute for lambda
to the d minus 2 Kd T star
on what we have over here.
And you get this to
be d minus n minus 1
over 2n minus 2 epsilon.
And again, to be consistent
to order of epsilon,
this d you will have to
replace with 2 plus epsilon.
And a little bit of
manipulation will give you
yh, which is 2 minus n minus 3
divided by 2n minus 2 epsilon.
I did this calculation of the
two exponents rather rapidly.
The reason for that is they
are not particularly useful.
That is, whereas
we saw that coming
from four dimensions the
epsilon expansion was very
useful to give us
corrections to the [? mean ?]
field values of 1/2, for
example, for mu to order of 10%
or so already by setting
epsilon equals to 1.
If I, for example, put
here epsilon equal to 1
to [? access ?] 3
dimensions, I will
conclude that mu, which
is the inverse of yT
is 1 in 3 dimensions
independent of n.
And let's say for super
fluid it is closer to 2/3.
And so essentially, this
expansion in some sense
is much further away from 3
dimensions than the 4 minus
epsilon coming
from 4 dimensions,
although numerically,
we would have
said epsilon equaled
1 to both of them.
So nobody really has taken
much advantage of this 2 plus
epsilon expansion.
So why is it useful?
The reason that this is
useful is the third case
that I have not
explained, yet, which
is, what happens if you sit
exactly in 2 dimensions, OK?
So if we sit exactly
in 2 dimensions,
this first term disappears.
And you can see
that the behavioral
is determined by
the second order
and [? then ?] depends
on the value of n.
So if I look at n, let's
say, that is less than 2,
then what I will see is
that along the temperature
axis, the quadratic
term-- the linear term
is absent-- the quadratic
term, let's say, for n
equals 1 is negative.
And you're being
pushed quadratically
very slowly towards 0.
The one example that
we know is indeed n
equals 1, the Ising model.
And we know that the Ising
model in 2 dimensions
has an ordered phase.
It shouldn't really even
be described by this
because there are
no Goldstone modes.
But n greater than 2, like
n equals 3-- the Heisenberg
model, is interesting.
And what we see is that here the
second order term is positive.
And it is pushing you
towards high temperatures.
So you can see a
disordered behavior.
And what this calculation
tells you that is useful
that you wouldn't
have known otherwise
is, what is the
correlation [? length? ?]
Because the recursion relation
is now dT by dl is, let's say,
n minus 2.
And my d equals to 2.
The lambda to the d
minus 2, I can ignore.
Kd is 2 pi from the [? solid ?]
angle divided by 2 pi squared.
So that's 1 over 2 pi
times T squared, OK?
So that's the recursion relation
that we are dealing with.
I can divide by
1 over T squared.
And then this becomes d
by dl of minus 1 over T
equals n minus 2
divided by 2 pi.
I can integrate this from, say,
some initial value minus 1 over
some initial temperature
to some temperature where
I'm at [? length ?]
[? scale ?] l.
What I would have on the right
hand side would be n minus 2
over [? 2yl ?], OK?
So I start very, very close
to the origin T equals 0.
So I have a very strong
coupling at the beginning.
So this factor is huge.
T is [? more than ?]
1 over T is huge.
I have a huge coupling.
And then I rescale to a point
where the coupling has become
weak, let's say some number
of order of 1, order of 1
or order of 0.
In any case, it is
overwhelmingly smaller
than this.
How far did I have to go?
I had to rescale
by a factor of l
that is related
to the temperature
that I started with
by this factor,
except that I forgot
the minus that I
had in front of the whole thing.
So the resulting l will
be large and positive.
And the correlation length--
the length scale at which
we arrived at the
coupling, which
is of the order of 1 or 0,
is whatever my initial length
scale was times this factor
that I have rescaled by,
b, which is e to the l.
And so this is a exponential
of n minus 1 over 2 pi
times 1 over T. The
statement is that if you're
having 2 dimensions, a
system of, let's say,
3 component spins-- and
that is something that
has a lot of experimental
realizations--
you find that as you go
towards low temperature,
the size of domains
that are ordered
diverges according to
this nice universal form.
And let's say around
1995 or so, when
people had these high
temperature superconductors
which are effectively 2
dimensional layers of magnets--
they're actually
antiferromagnets,
but they are still described
by this [INAUDIBLE] with n
equals 3-- there were
lots of x-ray studies
of what happens to the ordering
of these antiferromagnetic
copper oxide layers as you
go to low temperatures.
And this form was very
much used and confirmed.
OK, so that's really one thing
that one can get from this
analysis that has been
explicitly [? confirmed ?]
[? for ?] experiments.
And finally, there's
one case in this
that I have not mentioned
so far, which is n equals 2.
And when I am at n
equals 2, what I have is
that the first and second
order terms in this series
are both vanishing.
And I really at this stage don't
quite know what is happening.
But we can think
about it a little bit.
And you can see that if you are
n equals 2, then essentially,
you have a 1 component angle.
And if I write the theory
in terms of the angle theta,
let's say, between
neighboring spins,
then the expansions would simply
be gradient of theta squared.
And there isn't any other
mode to couple with.
You may worry a little bit
about gradient of theta
to the 4th and such things.
But a little bit of
thinking will convince you
that all of those
terms are irrelevant.
So as far as we can
show, there is reason
that essentially
this series for n
equals 2 is 0 at
all orders, which
means that as far as this
analysis is concerned,
there is a kind of a
line of fixed points.
You start with any
temperature, and you
will stay at that
temperature, OK?
Still you would say that even if
you have this gradient of theta
squared type of theory,
the fluctuations that you
have are solutions
of 1 over q squared.
And the integral of 1 over
2 squared in 2 dimensions
is logarithmically divergent.
So the more correct statement
of the Mermin-Wagner's theorem
is that there should
be no long range
order in d less
than or equal to 2.
Because for d equals
2 also, you have
these logarithmic
divergence of fluctuations.
So you may have thought that you
are pointing along, say, the y
direction.
But you average more
and more, and you
see that the extent of
the fluctuations in angle
are growing logarithmically.
You say that once that logarithm
becomes of the order of pi,
I have no idea
where my angle is.
There should be no
true long range order.
And I'm not going to try
to interpret this too much.
I just say that
Mermin-Wagner's theorem
says that there should
be no true long range
order in systems that have
continuous symmetry in 2
dimensions and below, OK?
And that statement is
correct, except that
around that same time, Stanley
and Kaplan did low temperature
series analysis-- actually,
no, I'm incorrect--
did high temperatures
series of these spin models
in 2 dimensions.
And what they found was,
OK, let's [? re-plot ?]
susceptibility as a
function of temperature.
We calculate our best
estimate of susceptibility
from the high
temperature series.
And what they do is, let's
say, they look at the system
that corresponds to n equals 3.
And they see that the
susceptibility diverges only
when you get in the
vicinity of 0 temperature,
which is consistent with all
of these statements that first
of all, this is a [? direct ?]
correlation [? when it ?] only
diverges at 0 temperature.
And divergence of susceptibility
has to be coupled through that.
And therefore, really,
the only exciting thing
is right at 0 temperature,
there is no region where
this is long range
order, except that when
they did the analysis
for n equals 2,
they kept getting
signature that there
is a phase transition at
a finite temperature in d
equals 2 for this xy
model that described
by just an [INAUDIBLE], OK?
So there is lots of numerical
evidence of phase transition
for n equals 2 in d
equals [? 2, ?] OK?
So this is another
one of those puzzles
which [INAUDIBLE]
if we interpret
the existence of a diverging
susceptibility in the way
that we are used to,
let's say the Ising model
and all the models
that we have discussed
so far, in all cases that
we have seen, essentially,
the divergence of
the susceptibility
was an indicator of the onset
of true long range order
so that on the other side, you
had something like a magnet.
But that is rigorously
ruled out by Mermin-Wagner.
So the question is, can
we have a phase transition
in the absence of
symmetry breaking?
All right?
And we already saw one example
of that a couple of lectures
back when we were doing the
dual of the 3-dimensional Ising
model.
We saw that the 3-dimensional
Ising model, its dual
had a phase transition but
was rigorously prevented
from having true
long range order.
So there, how did we distinguish
the different phases?
We found some appropriate
correlation function.
And we showed that that
correlation function
had different behaviors at
high and low temperature.
And these two different
behaviors could not be matched.
And so the phase
transition was an indicator
of the switch-over in the
behavior of the correlation
functions.
So here, let's examine
the correlation functions
of our model.
And the simplest
correlation that we
can think of for a system that
is described by unit spins
is to look at the spin at
some location and the spin
at some far away
location and ask
how correlated they
are to each other?
And so basically, there is
some kind of, let's say,
underlying lattice.
And we pick 2 points
at 0 and at r.
And we ask, what
is the dot product
of the spins that we have
at these 2 locations?
And clearly, this is invariant
under the [? global ?]
rotation.
What I can do is I can
pick some kind of axis
and define angles with
respect to some axis.
Let's say with respect
to the x direction,
I define an angle theta.
And then clearly, this
is the expectation value
of cosine of theta
0 minus theta r.
Now, this quantity
I can asymptotically
calculate both at
high temperatures
and low temperatures
and compare them.
So let's do a high T expansion.
For the high T expansion,
I sort of go back
to the discrete model and
say that what I have here
is a system that
is characterized
by a bunch of angles that I
have to integrate in theta i.
I have the cosine of
theta 0 minus theta r.
And I have a weight that wants
to make near neighbours to be
parallel.
And so I will write it as
product over nearest neighbors,
p to the K cosine of
theta i minus theta j.
OK, so the dot
product of 2 spins
I have written as the
cosine between [? nearest ?]
neighbors.
And of course, I have to
then divide by [INAUDIBLE].
Now, if I'm doing the high
temperature expansion,
that means that this
coupling constant K
scaled by temperature is known.
And I can expand this as 1 plus
K cosine of theta i minus theta
j [? plus ?] [? higher ?] orders
in powers of K of course, OK?
Now, this looks to
have the same structure
as we had for the Ising model.
In the Ising model, I had
something like sigma i sigma j.
And if I had a sigma
by itself and I
summed over the possible
values, I would get 0.
Here, I have something
like a cosine of an angle.
And if I integrate, let's say, d
theta 0 cosine of theta 0 minus
something, just because
theta 0 can be both positive
as [? it just ?] goes
over the entire angle,
this will give me 0.
So this cosine I
better get rid of.
And the way that I
can do that is let's
say I multiply cosine
of theta 0 minus theta r
with one of the
terms that I would
get in the expansion, such
as, let's say, a factor of K
cosine of theta 0 minus theta 1.
So if I call the
next one theta 1,
I will have a term
in the expansion that
is cosine of theta
0 minus theta 1, OK?
Then this will be non-zero
because I can certainly
change the origin.
I can write this as integral
d theta 0 minus theta 1--
I can call phi.
This would be cosine
of phi from here.
This becomes cosine of theta
0 minus theta 1 minus phi.
And this I can expand as
cosine of a 0 minus theta 1
cosine of phi minus sine
of theta 0 minus theta 1
sine of phi.
Then cosine integrated
against sine will give me 0.
Cosine integrated against
cosine will give me 1/2.
So this becomes 1/2 cosine of
theta 0 minus theta 1 theta r.
What did I-- For theta 0, I
am writing phi plus theta 1.
So this becomes phi plus
theta 1 minus theta r.
This becomes cosine of
This becomes theta
1 minus theta r.
OK, so essentially,
we had a term
that was like a cosine of theta
0 minus theta r from here.
Once we integrate
over this bond,
then I get a factor
of 1/2, and it
becomes like a connection
between these two.
And you can see that
I can keep doing that
and find the path that
connects from 0 to r.
For each one of the
bonds along this path,
I pick one of these factors.
And this allows me to
get a finite value.
And what I find once I do this
is that through the lowest
order, I have to count the
shortest number of paths
that I have between
the two, K. I
will get a factor of K.
And then from the averaging
over the angles, I will get 1/2.
So it would b K
over 2 [INAUDIBLE].
By this we indicate the
shortest path between the 2, OK?
So the point is that
K is a small number.
If I go further
and further away,
this is going to be
exponentially small
in the distance
between the 2 spaces,
where [? c ?] can be
expressed in something that
has to do with K.
So this is actually
quite a general statement.
We've already seen it
for the Ising model.
We've now seen it
for the xy model.
Quite generally, for systems
at high temperatures,
once can show that correlations
decay exponentially
in separation because
the information
about the state of one variable
has to travel all the way
to influence the other one.
And the fidelity by which the
information is transmitted
is very small at
high temperatures.
So OK?
So this is something that
you should have known.
We are getting the answer.
But now what happens if I go
and look at low temperatures?
So for low temperatures,
what I need to do
is to evaluate
something that has
to do with the behavior
of these angles
when I go to low temperatures.
And when I go to
low temperatures,
these angles tend to be very
much aligned to each other.
And these factors of
cosine I can therefore
start expanding around 1.
So what I end up having to do is
something like a product over i
theta i cosine of
theta 0 minus theta r.
I have a product over
neighbors of factors
such as K over 2 theta
i minus theta j squared,
[? as ?] I expand the
Gaussian, expand the cosine.
And in the denominator I would
have exactly the same thing
without this.
So essentially, we see
that since the cosine is
the real part of e to the i
theta 0 minus theta r, what
I need to do is to calculate
the average of this
assuming the Gaussian weight.
So the theta is Gaussian
distributed, OK?
Now-- actually, this [INAUDIBLE]
I can take the outside also.
It doesn't matter.
I have to calculate
this expectation value.
And this for any Gaussian
expectation value of e to the i
some Gaussian
variable is minus 1/2
the average of whatever
you have, weight.
And again, in case you forgot
this, just insert the K here.
You can see that this is
the characteristic function
of the Gaussian
distributed variable, which
is this difference.
And the characteristic
function I
can start expanding in
terms of the cumulants.
The first cumulant, the
average is 0 by symmetry.
So the first thing
that will appear,
which would be at the
order of K squared,
is going to be the
variance, which
is what we have over here.
And since it's a Gaussian,
all higher order terms
in this series [? will. ?]
Another way to do
is to of course just
complete the square.
And this is what
would come out, OK?
So all I need to do is to
calculate the expectation
value of this quantity
where the thetas are
Gaussian distributed.
And the best way to do so
is to go to Fourier space.
So I have integral.
For each one of these factors
of theta 0 minus theta r,
I will do an integral
d2 q 2 pi squared.
I have 1 minus e
to the iq.r, which
is from theta 0 minus theta r.
And then I have a theta tilde q.
I have two of those factors.
I have d2 q prime 2 pi squared.
I have e to the minus iq prime
dot r theta tilde q prime.
And then this average
simply becomes this average.
And the different modes are
independent of each other.
So I will get a 2 pi
to the d-- actually,
2 here, a delta
function q plus q prime.
And for each mode,
I will get a factor
of Kq squared because
after all, thetas
are very much like the pi's that
I had written at the beginning,
OK?
So what I will have is that this
quantity is integral over one
q's.
Putting these two
factors together,
realizing that q
prime is minus q
will give me 2 minus 2 cosine
of q.r divided by Kq squared.
So there is an
overall scale that
is set by 1 over
K, by temperature.
And then there's a function
[? on ?] [? from ?],
which is the Fourier transform
of {} 1 over q squared, which,
as usual, we call C. We
anticipate this to be like
a Coulomb potential.
Because if I take
a Laplacian of C,
you can see that-- forget the
q-- the [? Laplacian ?] of C
from the cosine, I will get a
minus q squared cancels that.
I will have [INAUDIBLE]
d2q 2 pi squared.
Cosine itself will be left.
The 1 over q squared disappears.
This is e to the iqr you plus
e to the minus iqr over 2.
Each one of them gives
a delta function.
So this is just
So C is the potential that
you have from a unit charge
in 2 dimensions.
And again, you can perform
the usual Gaussian procedure
to find that the gradient
of C times 2 pi r
is the net charge that is
enclosed, which is [? unity ?].
So gradient of C, which
points in the radial direction
is going to be 1 over 2 pi r.
And your C is going to be
log of r divided by 2 pi.
So this is 1 over K log
of r divided by 2 pi.
And I state that when
essentially the 2 angles are
as close as some short distance
cut-off, fluctuations vanish.
So that's how I set the
0 of my integration, OK?
So again, you put
that over here.
We find that s0.s of r in
the low temperature limit
is the exponential
of minus 1/2 of this.
So I have log of r over
a divided by 4 pi K.
And I will get a over r to
the power of 1 over 4 pi K.
And I kind of want to check
that I didn't lose a factor of 2
somewhere, which I seem to have.
Yeah, I lost a factor
of 2 right here.
This should be 2
because of this 2,
if I'm using this definition.
So this should be 2.
And this should be 2 pi K. OK.
So what have we established?
We have looked as a
function of temperature
what the behavior of this
spin-spin correlation function
is.
We have established that in
the higher temperature limit,
the behavior is something
that falls off exponentially
with separation.
We have also established
that at low temperature,
it falls off as a power
law in separation, OK?
So these two functional
behaviors are different.
There is no way that you can
connect one to the other.
So you pick two spins that
are sufficiently far apart
and then move the separation
further and further away.
And the functional form
of the correlations
is either a power-law
decay, power-law decay,
or an exponential decay.
And in this form, you know
you have a high temperature.
In this form, you know you
have a low temperature.
So potentially, there could be
a phase transition separating
the distinct behaviors of
the correlation function.
And that could
potentially be underlying
what is observed over here, OK?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So where could
we make the assumption
we're at a low temperature
in the second expansion?
PROFESSOR: When we expanded
the cosines, right?
So what I should really do is to
look at the terms such as this.
But then I said that I'm low
enough temperature so that I
look at near neighbors, and
they're almost parallel.
So the cosine of the angle
difference between them
is the square of
that small angle.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
OK?
So actually, you
may have said that I
could have done the same
analysis for small angle
expansions not only
for n equals 2,
but also for n
equals 3, et cetera.
That would be correct.
Because I could have made a
similar Gaussian analysis for n
equals e also.
And then I may have
concluded the same thing,
except that I cannot conclude
the same thing because of this
thing that we derived over here.
What this shows is that the
expansion around 0 temperature
regarded as Gaussian
is going to break down
because of the
non-linear coupling
that we have between modes.
So although I may be tempted to
write something like this for n
equals 3, I know
why it is wrong.
And I know the
correlation length
at which this kind
of behavior will
need to be replaced with
this type of behavior
because effectively, the
expansion parameter became
of the order of 1.
But I cannot do that
for the xy model.
I don't have similar reason.
So then the question
becomes, well,
how does this expansion then
eventually break down so
that I will have a phase
transition to a phase
where the correlations are
decaying exponentially?
And you may say,
well, I mean, it's
really something
to do with having
to go to higher and
higher ordered terms
in the expansion of the cosine.
And it's going to
be something which
would be very difficult to
figure out, except that it
turns out that there is a
much more elegant solution.
And that was proposed
by [? Kastelitz ?]
and [? Thales. ?]
And they said that what you
have left out in the Gaussian
analysis are
topological defects, OK?
That is, when I did the
expansion of the cosine
and we replaced the cosine with
the difference of the angles
squared, that's
more or less fine,
except that I should also
realize that cosine maintains
its value if the angle
difference goes up by 2 pi.
And you say, well,
neighboring spins are never
going to be 2 pi
different or pi different
because they're very
strongly coupled.
Does it make any difference?
Turns out that, OK, for
the neighboring spins,
it doesn't make a difference.
But what if you go far away?
So let's imagine that this is,
let's say, our system of spins.
And what I do is I look at a
configuration such as this.
Essentially, I have
spins [? radiating ?] out
from a center such as this, OK?
There is, of course,
a lot of energy costs
I have put over here.
But when I go very
much further out,
let's say, very far
away from this plus sign
that I have indicated
over here, and I
follow what the behavior
of the spins are,
you see that as I go along
this circuit, the spins start
by pointing this way,
they go point this way,
this way, et cetera.
And by the time I carry
a circuit such as this,
I find that the angle theta
has also rotated by 2 pi, OK?
Now, this is clearly
a configuration
that is going to be costly.
We'll calculate its cost.
But the point is that there
is no continuous deformation
that you can make
that will map this
into what we were
expanding around here
with all of the cosines
being parallel to each other.
So this is a topologically
distinct contribution
from the Gaussian
one, the Gaussian term
that we've calculated.
Since the direction of
the rotation of the spins
is the same as the direction
of the circuit in this case,
this is called a plus
topological defect.
There is a corresponding
minus defect
which is something like this.
OK, and for this, you
can convince yourself
that as you make a
circuit such as this
that the direction
of the arrow actually
goes in the opposite
direction, OK?
This is called a negative
sign topological defect.
Now, I said, well,
let's figure out
what the energy cost of
one of these things is.
If I'm away from the center
of one of these defects,
then the change in angle
is small because the change
in angle if I go all the way
around a circle of radius
r should come back to be 2 pi.
2 pi is the uncertainty that
I have from the cosines.
So what I have is
that the gradient
of theta [? between ?]
neighboring angles
times 2 pi r, which is
this radius, is 2 pi.
And this thing,
here it is plus 1.
Here it is minus 1.
And in general, you can
imagine possibilities
where this is some integer
that is like 2 or minus 2
or something else
that is allowed
by this degeneracy
of this cosine, OK?
So you can see that
when you are far away
from the center of
whatever this defect is,
the gradient of theta has
magnitude that is n over r, OK?
And as you go
further and further,
it becomes smaller and smaller.
And the energy cost out here
you can obtain by essentially
expanding the cosine is going
to be proportional to the change
in angle squared.
So the cost of the
defect is an integral
of 2 pi rdr times this quantity
n over r squared multiplied
by the coefficient of the
expansion of the cosine,
or K over 2.
And this integration I
have to go all the way to
ends up of my system.
Let's call it l.
And then I can
bring it down, not
necessary to the scale
of the lattice spacing,
but maybe to scale of 5 lattice
spacing or something like this,
where the approximations that
I have used of treating this
as a continuum are still valid.
So I will pick some kind of
a short distance cut-off a.
And then whatever energy is
at scales that are below a,
I will add to a core energy that
depends on whatever this a is.
I don't know what that is.
So basically, there
is some core energy
depending on where I stop this.
And the reason that
this is more important--
because here I have an
integral of 1 over r.
And an integral of 1
over r is something
that is logarithmically
divergent.
So I will get K. I
have 2 cancels the 2.
I have pi en squared
log of l over a, OK?
So you can see that creating
one of these defects
is hugely expensive.
And energy that as your system
becomes bigger and bigger
and we're thinking
about infinite
sized systems is
logarithmically large.
So you would say these
things will never
occur because they cost an
infinite amount of energy.
Well, the thing is that
entropy is also important.
So if I were to calculate the
partition function that I would
assign to one of these
defects, part of it
would be exponential
of this energy.
So I would have this e to
the minus this core energy.
I would have this exponential of
K pi n squared log of l over a.
So that's the [INAUDIBLE]
weight for this.
But then I realize that
I can put this anywhere
on the lattice so there is
an entropy [? gain ?] factor.
And since I have assigned this
to have some kind of a bulk
to it as some
characteristic size a,
the number of distinct
places that I can put it
is over the order
of l over a squared.
So basically, I take my huge
lattice and I partition it
into sizes of a's.
And I say I can put it in any
one of these configurations.
You can see that
the whole thing is
going to be e to the
minus this core energy.
And then I have l over
a to the power of 2
minus pi K n squared, OK?
So the logarithmic energy
cost is the same form
as the logarithmic entropy
gain that you have over here.
And this precise balance will
give you a value of K such
that if K is larger than
2 over pi n squared,
this is going to be an
exponentially large cost.
There is a huge
negative power of l here
that says, no, you don't
want to create this.
But if K becomes weak such
that the 2, the entropy factor,
[? wins ?], then you will
start creating [INAUDIBLE].
So you can see that
over here, suddenly we
have a mechanism along
our picture over here,
maybe something like K,
which is 2 over pi, such
that on one side you
would say, I will not
have topological defect and
I can use the Gaussian model.
And on the other side, you
say that I will spontaneously
create these
topological defects.
And then the
Gaussian description
is no longer valid because
I have to now really take
care of the angular nature
of these variables, OK?
So this is a nice picture, which
is only a zeroed order picture.
And to zeroed order,
it is correct.
But this is not fully correct.
Because even at
low temperatures,
you can certainly create hairs
of plus minus defects, OK?
And whereas the
field for one of them
will fall off at
large distances,
the gradient of
theta is 1 over r,
if you superimpose what is
happening for two of these,
what you will convince
yourself that if you have
a pair of defects of
opposite sign at the distance
d that the distortion that they
generate at large distances
falls off not the as 1 over
r, which is, if you like,
a monopole field, but
as d over r squared,
which is a dipole field.
So whenever you
have a dipole, you
will have to multiply
by the separation
of the charges in the dipole.
And that is compensated
by a factor of 1
over r in the denominator.
There is some
angular dependence,
but we are not so
interested in that.
Now, if I were to
integrate this square,
we can see that it
is something that
is convergent at
large distances.
And so this is
going to be finite.
It is not going to diverge as
the size of the system, which
means that whereas individual
defects there was no way
that I could create
in my system,
I can always create
pairs of these defects.
So the correct picture
that we should have
is not that at low temperatures
you don't have defects,
at high temperatures you have
these defects spontaneously
appearing.
The correct picture is
that at low temperatures
what you have is lots and lots
of dipoles that are pretty much
bound to each other.
And when you go to high
temperatures, what happens
is that you will have these
pluses and minuses unbound
from each other.
So if you like,
the transition is
between molecules to a plasma
as temperature is changed.
Or if you like, it is between
an insulator and a conductor.
And how to mathematically
describe this phase transition
in 2 dimensions, which
we can rigorously,
will be what we will do in
the next couple of lectures.